hi I'm Christopher Hine and for our
regular weekly video this week uh I'm
going to show you the an overview video
for edim nag so edim nag is another
technique that I think Super pivotal
iido and is also really confusing as to
what it is I clarify edim Minag in a in
a very simple way for my school and the
way we study that might be different
than the way it's clarified for you at
your school but I think you're going to
recognize pretty much everything we do
as regular Ed Minag but the way I talk
about it might be a little different for
you um so this is how I talk about Ed
Minag and my concept of what edag is and
I'm going to kind of go over all the
little variations on it and what really
makes Ed Minag an edag as far as I'm
concerned I'm going to call Josh over
here we're going to go to work joshh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so let's talk a little bit
about Ed Minag and what Ed Minag is
clarification of terms really quick some
styles of iido call what I call KAG Ed
Minag right and so um this in some
schools is called an ed Minag I just
don't call it that there's no reason why
not to call it that I just don't use the
name um I call an ed Minag any throw
that happens from back here so back here
makes edim Minag that's why it's an edim
Minag the form that's created after that
isn't what makes it edim nag what makes
it edag is it's a throw that happens
from the EDI position right so if Josh
and I are facing each other here and I
come back behind him like this then I've
made the EDI right so actually let me
have you there we go okay so I'm here
and I come back I shoot back here okay
now I've made EDI any throw that happens
now is EDI nag right okay now that's a
little bit I'm Taking Liberties with
that and why I'm taking those Liberties
is because it makes a whole grouping of
techniques make sense together and those
things can kind of be confusing if you
don't name them that way so that's why I
use that convention I think I'm the only
school that uses that convention but
here's why I use it so when we get the
Ed position so let me just have you
sideways here okay so now I've made Ed
right this is the good position Now
understand I could just want to escape
from this position or I could want to
attack him or I could want to do all
kinds of things to him but what he's
going to want to do no matter what is
get out of the Ed me position so that's
what he's going to want to do right so
he just wants to in some way get around
okay so I have to have a set of skills
that keeps him from doing that so
regardless of what I want to do right
and so I know that like you know the
common thing when we're thinking about
iido in this era we're having right now
is that like oh I I must want to get
there to do something to him whether
that's true or not he is going to want
to do something and that what he wants
to do is to turn around so I need to
have a set of skills for that okay now
one thing and this is not going to look
like eating Minag to you guys at all but
after I I follow it up you you'll make
sense to you one thing I can do to help
me if he tries to do that is
this okay so if I shove him away from me
when he turns around I will have the
distance I want right so remember I had
to go e because there was a positioning
Pro or a distancing problem that became
a positioning problem right so what I
mean by that is if we were at our ideal
distance and he breaks it down so he's
faster than me or whatever I now have a
positioning problem so a distance
problem turned into a positioning
problem when I position I no longer have
a positioning problem but if he turns
back around he just counteracted
everything I did so if I were simply to
shove this guy away from me I now have
distance so not only did I solve my
positioning problem I made it a
distancing problem again which is what I
want so I'm up cycling right so I'm
going up up in cycles of what I want
right okay so that's really good for me
all right now A that's not always going
to work and b sometimes well let's just
go with a first so so when we're here if
he turns really cleverly right into me
and I shove him this is what's going to
happen right okay so I can't get that
shove off because he's just going to
turn right around it now if as he turns
around it I go here we start to get what
looks like a classic edting Minag to
people right so and I think a lot of
people have the idea that edim Minag is
a clothline I don't really think in any
style of iido that edim Minag is a
clothes line I think what it
consistently is is a controlling of the
head so here I have Josh's head
controlled so if Josh tries to turn
towards me that really sucks right and
the more he tries to turn towards me the
more he comes off balance which is good
for me because now he can't get the
position he wants so this is the
foundation of why our Ed Minag happen I
got to the Ed position and then from the
edme position this guy is going to want
to do something to me so how do I head
that off all right now I said you know
this doesn't look that much like an ed
Minag um but I'll show you why it does
look like it so in some styles of iido
you will see where uh someone comes back
here and they grab the collar and they
drive this guy down to the mat like this
and then as he comes up I throw Ed Minag
now if you're like me you saw that and
you said
uh that's that's a dumb thing to do why
would you push someone down and then
pull them up and then throw them well I
believe what's being shown in that form
is me doing essentially this right and
when I do it Josh is doing essentially
the thing I showed you he could do which
is this okay and then he got low right
which is even smart so he added a step
to it which is he got low which makes it
even harder for me to control right okay
and then when he does that I stick with
him and try to shove him down so I'm
trying to push him down because he
already went low then he doesn't want to
go low so he comes up and there's where
our Yim Minag comes off okay so that
whole form I think is showing a series
of throws that is going incorrectly
right so that's why I think we need to
kind of put it together in this way to
make sense out of what edim nag is edim
nag is simply a throw that happens once
you've achieved the idimi position now
that throw can be a lot of things right
so uh when I did styles of kung fu and
you see yba do this too uh we learned to
grab the neck and drive him back like
this right so that could be Ed Minag
right I could get tight to him here and
as he turns that could be Ed Minag cyto
Sensei likes to emphasize pulling the
collar or hitting the hips those could
be Ed Minag right could be like in IAI
Styles where you see them drive them
down to the ground and pick them back up
that could be an ed nag so any throw
that happens after the edei position has
been achieved and the throw is happening
because he won't want me to be here
right he'll want to adjust this to an
advantageous position to him anytime a
throw comes off there that is an Ed
nuget and there's lots and lots of ways
those could play out so I'm not going to
go into a ton of the details I think I
gave you enough of the the pieces to
work with if you guys want to see
specific details on how the Ed Naga
techniques come off I can do those but I
think this this really should start to
reframe it for you and if you allow this
reframing to kind of come into your
perception as you look at your details
for the techniques they'll probably
start hashing out because that's kind of
what happened to me is once once I
started saying oh I think edim nag
should just be a throw that comes after
the EDI then as I looked at other iido
styles I was like oh that's why they're
doing this here and why they're doing
this here and it all began to make a lot
more sense to me so I think this is a a
nice overview to start to look at idag
idag is like KAG in that it's a
technique that a lot of people say oh
that's an edim Minag when you're like I
don't know if that's an idag why is that
an edag but in my school it's really
simple if they've achieved the edmi
position and then whatever is happening
to keep him from getting out of the Ed
position a throw happens a projection
happens then that is an ed me nag all
right so I am Christopher Hine this is
Joshua TI Mya Sal McDaniels now hiding
behind that camera right over there and
she gave one of these so we know she's
there you guys don't but I know she's
there Josh knows she's there right yep
all right anyways we'll see you guys in
some future videos thanks a lot
a